people have been noshing on shrimp since
the beginning of time but it hasn't
always been an easy catch wild stocks
declined in the 20th century shrimp
Farms emerged to supply what nature
couldn't factories process the Harvest
ensuring an abundance of Ready-to-Eat
shrimp for the freezer
[Music]
shrimp have long been big on the
cocktail circuit today it comes prepped
and Frozen complete with cocktail sauce
just unwrap and thaw
[Music]
shrimp cocktail is one of many
Ready-to-Eat dishes prepared at this
Factory in Thailand
fresh from the farm the shrimp undergoes
a quick Cold Water Rinse
it then rides a perforated conveyor
rinse water drains through the holes in
the conveyor to keep the shrimp from
becoming soggy
still cool from the icy bath the curly
Crustaceans spill off the conveyor into
plastic baskets
[Music]
they weigh each
and then transfer the shrimp to a larger
tub
[Music]
Chill on they add crushed ice between
loads a temperature of 10 degrees
Celsius or less must be maintained
throughout processing or quality will
suffer
it's now time for the inevitable the D
heading using a metal tool that's like
an open thimble workers pull the heads
off the shrimp with a few quick Tugs
[Music]
the deheading line is a long and busy
one
[Music]
headless shrimp now travel to sizing
rollers
space between the rollers is narrow at
first and wider further down as the
rollers spin smaller shrimp fall through
first and the larger ones continue on to
fall through further down
they accumulate in different piles on
conveyors below this separates the
shrimp into five size categories out of
the sorter an employee samples the
shrimp's temperature to confirm that it
remains adequately chilled
foreign
de-headed and sorted by size these
shrimp are now ready to come out of
their shells
on the shelling line some workers cut
the tails off and others leave them on
because there's a market for both
after they peel away the shell they cut
out the digestive tract that runs along
the back it's often referred to as the
vein because it looks like one workers
on this line peel and devein 800 shrimp
an hour
the shrimp then goes to different prep
zones at this one an employee dips tail
on shrimp into an egg mixture and then
dredges them in rice flour
sends them down the line to the next
worker
he rolls the flour shrimp in net rice
paper
[Music]
as you can see there's a bit of a trick
to this
[Music]
he moistens the edges of the rice paper
to seal the wrap
the result is a spring roll appetizer
that can be frozen until it's ready to
be cooked and served
in another area a worker prepares a
breaded recipe again using shrimp with
the Tails still on this is finger food
and with the tails on the shrimp will be
easier to grip he soaks it in seasonings
and coats it in breadcrumbs
then he dips it in egg batter and breads
it again
the second coating of crumbs will give
the shrimp extra crunch when fried
the tray is now full and so it's over to
the fry belt
after a quick trip through Hot Oil the
breaded shrimp is perfectly fried
all the shrimp including this raw
product take a blustery ride through a
freezer
spread evenly across the conveyor they
freeze individually rather than in big
icy clumps so you don't have to thaw a
whole bunch to get a few shrimp the
frozen shrimp falls into way stations at
the correct amount the bottom opens to
release them an ice glaze will protect
them from freezer burn
s frozen shrimp products are ready to
leave the factory
from the freezer to the oven to your
taste buds with all the prep work done
at the factory these frozen shrimp
products are quite a treat
[Music]
foreign
is an integral part of the Asian diet so
it's not surprising to find special
storage vessels for it in Thailand the
traditional container is a rice box a
covered jar hand woven from bamboo and
often beautifully decorated they're also
produced as decorative items for export
Thai rice boxes started out as ordinary
household containers for cooked sticky
rice today they're sought after
handicrafts produced in a range of sizes
for storage of all kinds or simply for
decoration
each box is hand crafted from start to
finish the Artisan begins with thin
strips of bamboo he splits the strips
with his fingernail to make them the
width required for the box size he's
weaving
he lines up the first few strips on the
floor and holds them steady with his
foot as he weaves strips crosswise
through them in a under one over two
sequence
he continues weaving this pattern until
he produces a square that's large enough
to form the base of the box
he sprays the base with water to soften
up the bamboo this prevents the strips
from breaking when he now bends them
upward to begin weaving the sides of the
box
[Music]
once he's completed the sides he begins
weaving the Box's neck pulling the
strips laterally in a circular Direction
he alternates folding one strip upward
one strip downward
trims the downward strips
then inserts the ends through the woven
sides
[Music]
next pulling the strips through the
middle he fits a bamboo ring over the
outside of the neck then another along
the inside of the neck locking the
remaining upward strips in between
this immobilizes the strips eliminating
any need for nails or glue
it also adds rigidity reinforcing the
next round shape
a quick trim of the remaining strips and
the box is fully constructed
foreign
using the same materials and technique
[Music]
Artisans coat the outside of the box and
lid with a mixture of chalk glue and
sawdust they let the coating dry in the
Sun for a day or two until the surface
becomes hard and smooth like clay
[Music]
now an artist gets to work
first applying two base coats of acrylic
paint
[Music]
once the base coats are dry she places
the box on a turntable and applies a
coat of the background color
[Music]
once that dries she begins outlining the
design
[Music]
fills in the design
once that's dry the fine details
it's here that you see the Artistry
emerge
[Music]
once the artwork has dried they encircle
the net with a band of Rattan then with
strips of Rattan tie the box to a wooden
stand
[Music]
at the base of each Corner they weave
the Rattan strips into a decorative
pattern
[Music]
not only is the rice box entirely
handmade The Artisans never use
templates never take measurements they
do it all by eye
inside of the Box remains bare the idea
is to see the bamboo and how skillfully
it's woven
it's a natural non-toxic surface against
which it's safe to store rice